at his Newport Street Gallery the art
worlds on fontaribler had something
cooking Damien Hurst announcing his
presence by casually setting fire to
almost 10 million pounds worth of work
and when asked if he worries about the
morality of essentially burning money
during a cost of living crisis this is
what he had to say I'm not burning my
heart I'm transforming it
Hurst calls this the currency and has
produced 10 000 of these individual dot
works on paper but also as virtual
tokens or nfts and anyone could apply to
buy one for two thousand dollars which
is a bit of a bargain for rehearse but
if you did win one you get a choice keep
the physical work to hang on your wall
or opt to burn it and keep the digital
rights to say use it as a stupidly
expensive screensaver but knowing how
lucrative art in the virtual Market can
be so here opted to keep the physical
work but Kyle went for the nft nfts are
too new for me
um whereas having something I can hold
I prefer that if I try and tell my mum
I've got a picture of a picture that's
going to be burned it doesn't make sense
but when you think of it as sort of
it's the future it is an art form it's
digital we all have a phone there are
plenty of people who find nfts just as
perplexing as the huge amounts Damien
hurst's work continues to sell for that
rage about what's happening virtually
perhaps best summed up by the art critic
from the times who described what's
happening here as a stunt and the whole
concept of nfts has been invented by the
devil to lure fools into the art world
and persuade them to spend their money
on nothing
first will have to be on hand with his
fire extinguisher for quite some time
with
4851 pieces to burn
and we're just here to try and record
today
future
wow heavy well some might argue there's
no place for publicity stunts in art
love him or loathe him Damien Hurst
certainly knows how to not only test the
boundaries but also push buttons Casey
Spencer Sky News